let me jump to this next story we'll
keep the conversation going
donald trump warns terrible things are
about to happen to the u.s
this to me actually is more serious than
i think a lot of people probably realize
on the surface
the former president said that the
temperature because the temperature has
to be brought down in this country he's
offering uh his any assistance to the
doj
to try and calm things down
he says if it isn't terrible things are
going to happen
i think donald trump realizes when you
see these the story from axios about a
guy threatening fbi agents about a guy
going to an fbi field office
about uh i mean just the fact they're
going after a president it's not so much
that trump realizes
he's in trouble that they're coming
after him but people are ready to snap
in this country and the left has long
been ready to snap they've been snapping
for a while and now their rights ready
to go out when trump says something like
this
this creates in my mind an image of
trump sitting down at a desk like dead
serious more serious he's ever been
being like
this is bad
this is real bad and i think when trump
notices it it's probably worse than we
even realize
i have to wonder what a secret service
detail is telling him or the things that
he might be seeing
and um i think the left's view of this
probably like ah trump's trying to save
his own skin right
yes he's saying it's look hey there's a
big problem coming for us when what he
means is for me
and then people have a tendency to
externalize their own fears when they're
really in in trouble
i don't i don't think that's what it is
i mean i think he's talking about food
shortages i think he's talking about
inflation that it's all going to get
worse
that things that tensions are high now
but it's going to get much worse you you
and i think that part of it's going to
be
biden's already announced yeah we're
probably looking at some food shortages
he did that months ago i mean it's going
to get bad and then when you start
having bread lines in america you you
see you know i see news reports where
all the food banks are now have you know
40 50 percent increase in how many
people are lining up for food i mean it
if that starts happening then you're
going to see violence do you think that
was the richest country on the earth's
ever seen have you like you've given up
have you given up do you feel like it's
inevitably going to fall apart and then
just i think that there are forces
within our government that are making it
happen that want it to happen they are
they're trying to force a civil war
what's if you if you accept the premise
like i do that the left is literally
trying to destroy this country they hate
it they hate the constitution they hate
the country is founded they've been
teaching our children for decades in
school that this is a racist evil
country if you think that if you accept
the premise that they want to destroy it
what's the quickest way to do that the
quickest way is the civil war
and not only that the one way to get rid
of a constitution yeah so you can
destroy a civil war by a road i mean you
can destroy a country by eroding it the
problem is when you have a constitution
they struggle you know 100 years on
they've been trying to get rid of the
second amendment and boy it's just not
really working out all that well because
there's new advancements new
technologies they keep kind of passing
they keep to keep they keep trying to
pass new bills there's active resistance
if there was no constitution they'd have
banned guns
1850s right 1860 right in the civil war
okay nobody can have guns but us because
you know but they can
there's one way to get rid of it and
that's having a civil war so i have to
wonder
if it's uh china
as many people speculate china's
influence in this one and recently on a
russian state tv program
the they were talking about the house
were talking about a civil war is likely
coming to the u.s because the fbi raided
donald trump and one of the hosts said
the only question is which side do we
support with weapons
and i think that exemplifies the world
during the american revolution france
came in with troops and funding because
they knew it was basically help for them
in their fight with britain and they
knew was going to be bad for their
enemies
during the civil war the american civil
war there was funding coming from
external countries to the north and
south because there was a bet on who was
going to win and your investments were
riding on it the cia's funding regime
changes has been doing it for decades
decades i cannot imagine that another
the other countries are not that their
versions of cia are not doing that in
the united states they in fact i would
guess that they are
is
essentially attempting to create coups
within the united states probably have
been for decades yuri besmonov talks
about like this slow sure you know
change of culture is the way to get a
country to change so you don't have to
blow anything up um
uh yeah i don't know if it's a ccp i
can't blame china because they're under
occupation by the ccp right now except
for taiwan
except for the republic the republic
stands in taiwan at the moment it would
be really cool if like you know 50 years
we're looking back and like the republic
of china took back over
ccp collapses that's that's the path
that we're on you think so taiwan is
eventually going to regain control i
think the people of china will revolt
they tried in 91 it but the
the ccp mowed down people in tiananmen
square i'll get a lot of i probably will
get people responding me like ian you've
got the history all wrong because i am
looking at it through an american lens
of media but i remember seeing the tank
driving on the street the guy waving his
hands to be like hey
i'm i'm a chinese man i'm sovereign
don't you you don't live here don't you
don't control me and the tanks just like
try to go around them then they they ran
them off i thought he was just holding
the bags
i thought he was just holding bags yeah
yeah and then he was like waving
something around like a suitcase or bags
or something like that yep so you said
that you think it's in the government
like like working for the us government
the people have been co-opted by
external governance enemies foreign and
domestic why do you think that well i
think that our government has been
corrupted especially the biden family i
mean you take look at all the money
that's come out of china to the biden
family to come out of ukraine to the
biden family i mean there there's
serious payoffs there and they're not
the only ones i mean
a lot of foreign money has flown uh has
has gone to the clinton family to
even the romney family i mean there's a
lot of corruption here and a lot of
people are protecting their financial
interests and are selling out the united
states and you have that combination
of of as yuri basma but what's his name
basmanov besmanov besamoff whatever yeah
the long march through the institutions
they have corrupted our our educational
system so that you have generation after
generation increasingly hating this
country increasingly feeling like oh
capitalism is really the problem
and so it's it's a combination of all
those things it's not just a foreign
enemy and it's not just domestic enemies
it's a combination of everything it's
have you seen that movie everything
everywhere all at once yeah i really
really liked it but it kind of feels
like in a sense
the multiverse is collapsing on on us
right now maybe maybe the large hadron
collider needs to stop firing up or
something but you've got 1984 brave new
world fairness 51 you got v for vendetta
you got atlas shrugged just you name it
and they are all getting mashed together
all at once people are commenting right
now like there's not going to be a civil
war it's world war three and i'm like
yeah that too yeah it's just like all
happening i find it hard not to think
about sri lanka right now because they
just had insane inflation and then their
president was like no no i'll step down
after people stormed his home and office
and then he got on a plane and still
hadn't resigned and left the country got
denied entry to singapore and kept going
on you know when you line it up it's
like we also have uh high inflation and
we also have a president that are a
former president that looks like he's
about to be indicted i mean the
instability is so parallel to countries
that i don't think americans are used to
comparing themselves to as as haughty as
that sounds uh and saying sri lanka is
like the dry run yeah i mean i think
it's hard not to be like you i mean they
you were just saying like well trump has
a president has a plane he could leave
on like
it's right there i mean
the sri lankan president because he was
president at the time took a military
plane and because he can't be uh
indicted or anything while he's a
sitting president left with it like it's
it sounds crazy
this is while people were storming his
office his house people were occupying
the prime minister's house like it
sounds crazy but at the same time you
know that kind of stress and chaos that
high inflation brings we are also
feeling it in america it's just on a
micro level in comparison it doesn't
mean that things can't get out of hand
in the same way and we're just not used
to being compared to countries that we
think we are more stable than
it's that belief that it can't happen
here it can't happen here we think this
all the time
even though it literally is
happening it's it's happening i mean
it's it's fascinating to look at
the circumstances in portland the
various circumstances i mean the
firebombing of the federal building but
um worse still is when aaron danielson
got shot twice in the chest by that blm
guy
so i mean the feds went after that dude
and claimed he had to win for a gun they
ended up killing him i'm like that's
kind of a crazy story
but you you take all the street level
violence and then you you add in the the
the big the big hits
the former president had his home raided
by the fbi
his former senior advisor i believe uh
bannon was
was what was ben's position
he was the adviser to the president
supervisor
yeah arrested being charged peter
navarro shackled
these things
are you know i mentioned this last week
but uh
i'm curious your thoughts uh nick when
we talk to people or when i read history
about some of these other countries
where civil war happened or revolution
happened
there's like always mass killings and
conflict and
they're they'll they always interview
somebody who left and nazi germany
always being the easiest example for
everybody why did so the jewish family
leaves right before the nazis rise to
power and why
and they say something like we saw them
dehumanizing and demonizing and thought
we better get out of here before it's
too late
then you had uh many even crystal
knocked
they you know the mass destruction of
these jewish businesses people still
stayed
you know despite everything but people
still fled when i see stuff like um the
former president being raided
when i see the fbi saying that symbols
of american history are are extremism
the betsy ross flag the gonzalez flag
the gadsden flag they're telling you
your own history is extremism like these
are all signs that in any other country
at any point other point in history
families were already fleeing seeking
safety in other countries it's happening
now here
i have a friend who told me a story
about talking to his niece about what
she learns in school and he said he said
she'd never heard of the u.s
constitution
she didn't even know what it was he said
don't you say the pledge of allegiance
at school anymore and they she said no
we say a pledge to blm and antifa
we say a pledge to diversity and
tolerance inclusion and they don't say
anything about the actual constitution
of the united states and how this
country was founded is this a private
school in california what is this it's a
it's a school in california is it a
public a public school i'm not sure
about that i got to get this pledge i
want a transcript of this i know i've
heard of this too i want to get it this
is the most wild pledge i've ever heard
of no i've
there's been tons of stories i think
libs of tick tock had the story where
the teacher was like we have them all
pledged to the lgbt flag or whatever
wasn't it it was buddha judge's
husband's husband yeah who had a camp
where they did that where they had yeah
so you could probably find a video of it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there